our daily routine begins with the sun
rising in the morning and setting in the
evening but in some areas this is not
the case in these areas which are
towards the poles of the Earth the North
and the South Poles there is a constant
sunlight for a long period of time even
close to six months and in some areas
there are complete darkness as well now
we know that the Earth is tilted 23 and
a half degrees on its axis so as a
result of that some areas are pointed
towards the Sun and some areas are
pointed away from the Sun and this
results in long periods of daylight and
darkness okay so now what are some
examples small volume novels for the
land of the midnight stars because for a
period of May to Late July which is a
period of about 76 days the Sun never
sets right and there are areas in
Antarctica who experience a similar
phenomenon of long periods of Darkness
or long periods of sunlight okay now
what do you think the videogritty of
these people who live in these areas
comment down below and for more such
fascinating videos subscribe to our
Channel